j'ai failli à bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors le secrétaire général de l'onu est
attendue donc aujourd'hui au liban un
déplacement de quatre jours alors que le
pays s'enlise dans la crise la pauvreté
qu'attendez-vous de cette visite du
secrétaire général de l'onu
ce que j'attends ce sont des mesures
concrètes il est important aujourd'hui
que l'on lui met la pression sur la
classe politique afin qu'il y ait de
véritables réformes financières
restructurer donc au secteur bancaire
public et privé là c'est la banque
centrale les banques il est très
important que également le il ya une
certaine pression qu'ils soient faites
sur le gouvernement afin qu'ils se
réunissent parce qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement de série ni plus en raison
du fait qu'il y ait une partie des
ministres qui qui veulent boycotter la
séance du conseil des ministres tant que
le juge d'investigation de l'explosion
du port continue son enquête
et il est également très important que
l'onu fasse pression sur l'événement et
est au désarmement peut-être des
palestiniens puisqu'on a vu les
l'explosion l'autre jour dans un camp
palestinien raison d'état
il est peut-être aussi important que
l'onu commence des négociations avec la
syrie qui essayent de revenir dans le
concert des nations afin que la syrie
donnent peut être des documents prouvant
la libanité des fermes de chébaa afin
que le enfin qu'ensuite le hesbollah des
armes ce désordre alors plusieurs
dossiers donc et on sait qu'il ya
toujours cette crise qui est lié au
traitement du juge chargé de l'enquêté
sur l'explosion du port de beyrouth vous
l'avez dit ça fait maintenant deux mois
que le gouvernement de transition ne
s'est pas réunie à votre avis antonio 8
et rêche peut-il vraiment faire
accélérer le processus pourquoi jusqu'à
maintenant rien n'a été fait de ce côté
là et qu'est ce qui bloque au sein du
gouvernement
je pense pas que le muc avis elle tire
quelque chose mais aussi le lieu est un
peu le soutien des principales
puissances
occidental et régionales il est peut
être possible d'en arriver à quelque
chose maintenant le gouvernement se
réunit pas comme vous le dites en raison
des la pression de certains partis afin
que l' enquête sur le port ne
poursuivent pas mais il ya également
d'autres partis qui ont un intérêt à ce
que le gouvernement ne se renie pas ce
sont les partis qui soutiennent en fait
c'est que la banque centrale est en
train de faire c'est-à-dire en fait le
dévaluer la livre libanaise et à couvrir
le peuple libanais
le peuple libanais qui souffrent on le
voit ce rapport alarmant de l'unicef
concernant les enfants qui sont en
danger à cause de la pauvreté
également des violences qu'ils peuvent
subir aujourd'hui quels sont les pays
qui viennent en aide économique
économiquement on va dire et
humanitairement au liban
juste pour vous dire vous serez dit que
le seuil de pauvreté et à un dollar par
jour donc prendre de la par mois
aujourd'hui le salaire minimum au liban
et de 24 dollars par mois donc vous
voyez ça ça n'est presque le trois
quarts des libanais sous le seuil de
pauvreté ça c'est très important à dire
ensuite au niveau des pays qui aident il
ya la france qui aide
et quelque peu un peu quelques heureuses
quelques autres pays occidentaux et
quelques pays
de la région comme le compare mais
cessons d aide qui reste limité parce
que tout le monde en fait souhaiter d
onu directement le peuple sans passer
par le gouvernement est important à un
moment donné de passer par le
gouvernement fait à travers un justement
ce plan de réforme qui est censé
remettre la confiance dans le long le
liban mais encore une fois le problème
c'est que ce gouvernement ne se réunit
pas il n'y a pas de plan de réforme il
n'y a donc pas de plan de
restructuration ce que je voudrais vous
expliquer aussi c'est que cette semaine
la banque centrale
en fait tu fais une circulaire qui
permet aux libanais et donc de retirer
des dollars mais en livres libanaises à
un taux
pire que celui d'avant donc en fait
c'est une conversion des dépôts en
livres libanaises et donc c'est un ce
qu'on appelle une décote en français
mais au liban on appelle ça un haircut
qui est en train d'être appliquée sur
l'argent des gens dans leur sur leurs
comptes bancaires donc est aujourd'hui
au lieu de faire payer les actionnaires
des banques l'état à la banque centrale
c'est bien le peuple qui est en train de
payer pour la dette que concret
justement les la banque centrale avec
l'aide des politiciens puissent qu'ils
avaient mis en place un schéma de ponzi
d'une pyramide de ponzi
dernière question c'est que antonio
guterres esch doit également réitéré son
appel à la tenue d'élections
législatives
elles sont prévues au printemps 2022
déjà à votre avis que voilà ça va ça le
pays il sera capable d'organiser ces
élections alors on sait que il ya
évidemment ce crise économique crise
politique et puis la crise sanitaire
également
oui ça reste une inconnue bien sûr tout
simplement je dire le pop pouces ce
qu'il y ait des élections il est
l'opposition pour ce qui est des
élections elle certains partis
traditionnels qui n'ont pas intérêt à ce
qu'il y ait ces élections et dans tous
les cas malheureusement les nouveaux
partis ne se sont pas structurés les
gens sont d'autres problèmes aujourd'hui
comme vous le dites les problèmes socio
économiques et donc il est fort à parier
qu'il y ait une très forte abstention
aux prochaines élections et que les
partis traditionnels l'emportent
notamment à travers le clientélisme
puisque justement les libanais ont
besoin d'eux d'argent pour survivre
juste pour vous dire un un point
important aujourd'hui on dit que
beaucoup de soldats dans l'armée
libanaise ont deux ou trois
emplois en plus de leur métier de soldat
donc c'est pour vous dire l'étendue de
la crise aujourd'hui au liban est là et
en fait ce que les gens se cherchent à
survivre et donc il ya plus cette cette
motivation de changement politique telle
qu'elle existait il ya deux ans merci
beaucoup en tout cas michel fayette
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique et financier